l'île de vancouver c'est l'endroit où le
parti vert a remporté son premier siège
là où il fonde beaucoup d'espoir durant
cette élection c'est aussi là où se
présentent d'événements un ancien
libéral maintenant candidat sous la
bannière écologistes et qu'est ce qui
vous a fait changer d'idée
c'était surtout les promesses brisées
j'ai quitté la journée ou à trudeau a
annoncé que les canadiens allaient
acheter le c'était la journée où je me
suis un joueur au parti vert
comme tous les candidats verts au pays
des mineurs doit convaincre les
électeurs que son parti est crédible et
qu'il s'appuie sur un programme
électoral complet quand les gens pensent
au parti vert souvent c'est le granulat
les sandales et gentil mais c'est
vraiment pas réaliste et donc ce que
vous dites que vous êtes un parti
complet finalement c'est ça un complet à
partie compliquée vraiment adresse la
justice sociale l'économie et
l'environnement
l'hiver ont évidemment des cibles
environnementales très ambitieuse ils
veulent mettre fin à l'expansion du
pipeline treatment in cesser de
subventionner l'industrie pétrolière et
aider les travailleurs du secteur à se
réorienter
ils promettent aussi d'interdire la
vente de voitures à essence d'ici 2030
l'hiver sont plus actifs sont plus
proactifs et vont dire non nous tout ce
qui est mauvais pour l'environnement on
arrête de les financer les partis verts
voient certainement vous dire oui c'est
réaliste
certains pourraient douter parce que
c'est très ambitieux sa demande de
changer l'économie
délaissée certains secteurs
traditionnels d'en développer des
nouveaux au delà de l'environnement les
verts ont plusieurs propositions
progressistes
ils promettent d'abolir les droits de
scolarité pour les étudiants d'instaurer
un revenu minimum garanti ou comme le
npd de mettre en place un régime
d'assurance médicament universel
comment payer pour tout ça on va
augmenter les taxes sur les plus riches
on va augmenter les taxes sur les bacs
sauf qu'en conférence de presse à
toronto la chef du parti vert elizabeth
may n'avait pas de chypre pour
accompagner sa plateforme désolait que
nous n'avons pas les chiffres
aujourd'hui c'est seulement une question
de quelques journées une chose est sûre
toutefois le parti vert avec sa
plateforme assez à gauche marche dans
les plates-bandes du npd d'ailleurs sur
l'île de vancouver les néo démocrates
qui détiennent la majorité des sièges
sentent la pression et accuse les verts
de ne pas avoir de direction politique
claire vous pensez pas que les verts
sont progressistes
ça me fait plutôt un parti tout partout
il est là l'un des grands défis du parti
vert durant cette élection car si le
programme d'elisabeth me et résolument à
gauche des canadiens de tous les
horizons se préoccupent maintenant de la
question climatique
le parti vert va recruter des gens
d'idéologies différentes qui ne
partagerons peut-être pas les valeurs
fondamentales qu'on a vu ces dernières
années ses partisans comme pour le
mouvement souverainiste hiver risque de
se rendre compte qu'il est parfois
difficile de rallier tout le monde
autour d'une même cause ici laurence
martin radio-canada victoria